off the coast of Brazil is an island so
dangerous that the Brazilian Navy has
expressly forbidden anyone from landing
there and you should definitely listen
to them locals love to recount two
grisly stories about this island and one
a local fisherman wants to pick some
bananas he gets out onto this island and
within minutes he's bitten by a snake he
runs back and jumps in his boat but it's
too late as he paddles away he passes
out and is found when the boat washes up
shore with him lying in a pool of his
own blood the second story is about a
lighthouse keeper who lived on this
island with his family one night they
made the disastrous mistake of leaving a
window open and through that window
climbed a dozen snakes they bit everyone
in the family and they died there inside
the lighthouse you'll see a theme in
these stories that's because this island
ilka hema de gran jay is also known as
snake island this small island 93 miles
off the coast of Brazil is the highest
density of poisonous snakes on the
planet researchers estimate that there
is one deadly snake for every square
metre that means you are never farther
than three feet from death the snakes
are only on this island there are an
endemic species it is part of the Lance
Head genus which is responsible for over
90% of the snake bite fatalities in
Brazil and they are notorious for loving
to hang out in the trees it's not just
that snakes are underfoot
they're also overhead you are in a
three-dimensional matrix of death by
snake this particular snake this golden
lancehead is one of the most venomous
snakes on the planet the way the venom
affects you is that it begins to
necrotize and corrupt your flesh from
the inside out
you basically start to melt should you
get bitten you have a maximum and this
is a absolute maximum of six hours to
get somewhere and
the antidote however it's just as likely
that you'll be dead in an hour so like
don't plan on a sick year like I yeah it
only takes me five hours to get to the
hospital you are in so much trouble what
are you doing on this island in the
first place actually don't go there
unfortunately researchers believe that
the snake population on the island has
decreased by as much as 50 percent
originally they were as high as five
snakes per square meter which is just
like there's just snakes like the island
is made of snakes and this is in large
part to poachers people who are going to
the island with the express purpose of
stealing these snakes because they are
so unique in the world
can fetch anywhere between ten and
thirty thousand dollars so despite the
terror of snake island the truth is with
the population of golden lance-heads
declining the snakes have a lot more to
fear from us than we do from them we can
just stay off the island which we should
because it's full of snakes subscribe
here and watch more videos here